okay can I just say one thing though so
is it not possible that calling god
father like the true Goda was something
only for the Jews because he had that
Covenant with them as a father no no
like for example is it is it only for
was it only for the Jews uh to refer to
God as only one God or can the non-jews
refer to God as multiple gods no so what
I'm saying is that specific lexicon like
that specific like usage of the term
like that was something they conceived
of themselves as being the sons of God
because they had that kind of a
relationship with they didn't conceive
of it that's what God revealed can you
show that to me yeah Deuteronomy 32:6 is
in the Torah is it uh is this the way
you repay the Lord you foolish and
unwise people is he not your father your
creator who made you and formed you okay
okay okay now I want you to go to the
gospel go to John really quick go to
John okay John one yeah verse 12 yet to
all who did receive him to those who
believed in his name he gave the right
to become children of God keep read it
what what happened what' you say finish
it oh finish it okay let me read the
full thing okay to all who did receive
him to name children born not of natural
descent nor of human decision or a
husband's will but born from God born
from God not from man's will not from
human flesh but born of God right so
you're spiritual children of God When
You Believe in the Messiah okay so you
have the Tor that reveals that God is
the father and you have the gospel that
reveals that God is the father to all
who believe in um Jesus Christ so anyone
everyone who believes is Will counted as
a Son of God a son or daughter of God
this completely goes against everything
Islam says
right you can only be a slave right you
can only be a servant that's it so but
would you not agree that there's
different degrees of servitude you can
be a righteous servant a wrathful
servant an ungrateful servant right yes
I agree that there you can be a good
servant or a bad servant but none of
these servants can be sons in Islam well
yeah no I but like even the angels even
the Jin even like any and all creation
everything ultimately is going to be
subject to two God's Will and two God's
just like ultimate Dominion but
according to Islam they're not Sons
right no they're not Sons we we don't
use the term like that's just what it is
we don't use the term it's not simply
that you don't use the term it's that
the Quran rejects the term so so I think
the verse you were talking about which
you said that it rejects it I think that
was talking in the context of Jesus
though no like when you say God took a
son it makes the heavens Rapture and the
Earth shake like that's in the context
of Jesus not just like any righteous
slave well yeah but I can grant that but
my thing is is that it eliminates that's
like a different claim that's anyone for
being a son not just Jesus well yeah but
I'm saying that specific verse is
talking about the Trinity no it's not it
has nothing to do with the Trinity just
has to do with the sunship of Jesus or
anybody else saying that anybody else is
a son so that's where I don't really see
eye to eye with you because I don't
think like the verse just isn't even
talking about that Concept in general it
again yeah it says there is no
one in the heaven or the Earth yeah this
only talking about Jesus or is it
talking about everyone in creation
that's talking about like just all
creation is
subject it says but can come to Allah
except as a s so there's not a single
creature that has ever come into
existence
that come to Allah as a son you can only
come to him as a slave right right done
deal so Jesus says that God is our
father and his father he's going
directly against the Quran and therefore
can't be a muslim okay but like I just
want to talk about that one verse like
that verse does not imply that you can't
also come to God as other things for
example the prophet Abraham in the Quran
is is s called a Wally of God a friend
of God right so he's not he's not a
slave of God in that context he's a
friend he's a slave that's a friend of
his yeah so you can be a slave in
multiple things to God can you be a son
and a slave okay that I don't know I'd
have to look at in the Sunnah to see if
there's anything that is about sunship
there but if I'm if I just take your
word for it no don't take my word for it
take the
Quan no because you you interpret the
Quran through the Sunnah too though no
you don't
you don't just take the Quran by itself
come on well the Quran says it's
detailed and explained about all things
so it
also I know what you're saying and I
grant you your position as a Sunni
Muslim that you also understand the
Quran through the lens of the through
the my point is this is that nowhere in
the Quran nor in the Sunnah does it
affirm that you can be a son of Allah
all we see
are rejections of this
idea is that really like such a big deal
though like you can come to Allah so
many other things a friend a righteous
person like so I got you here's the big
idea here's the big deal yeah if if
someone because we're talking about who
the true God is his identity right yes
the true God for example let's say the
true God in in is law he reveals himself
as one God now if someone comes and says
yeah I believe in the true God but he's
for Gods is it really that big of a deal
or is it is it a big deal it's a big
deal it is a big deal because they're
not talking about the true God they're
they're talking about something
completely different right so when God
reveals himself and he Reveals His
characteristics and he gives us his
identity that's who he is to say
anything otherwise you're not talking
about the true God anymore you're
talking about something false okay I I
get your point I get your point so if
God revealed himself as God our Lord and
whatever and he's not a father at all
watch what he says then to say that he's
a father is going directly against who
he revealed himself to be and you can't
you can't you're not talking about the
true God anymore so the way I would kind
of look contextualize that just like
from looking at it is that's more of
like a thing for the Jews Like For bani
Adam for sorry bunny Israel like that is
just how Revelation came to them through
the angels and like you know the angel
of the Lord and whatnot like they talked
about it in that way nice now let's see
what the Quran says about that remember
who whose word we gonna take mine or the
Quran the Quran so let's see what the
Quran has to say about what you just
said just trying to get them to believe
their own book man that's it I I just
want you guys to love the Quran more
than I do that's all okay okay so this
is Chapter 5 Verse 18 right the sunship
of Allah sunship of God something
special for the Jews right and that's
just a you know what they can do and
they have that relationship with God and
that you do know the concept of abreg is
in Islam right like there's different
Sharia for different uh time periods as
well so I'm not talking out of my ass
when I say this bro well you're saying
but you're saying different different
Sharia for different people right so
like for example the Quran says in 548
he says to each of you talking about the
Jews Christians and Muslims to each of
you we have prescribed to you your own
law right the Jews they follow the Torah
Christians they follow the gospel
Muslims they follow the Quran now
they're all supposed to believe in all
of the revelations but those particular
books are their laws that they have to
follow make sense okay so for Muslims
some things could be arreated for them
specifically that's not for the Jews or
the Christians right and vice versa yes
so okay so right here we're talking
about the Jews like what you just said
this is 5 Verse 18 it says but the Jews
and the Christians say we are the sons
of Allah this love just like you said
that's that's that's special for the
Jews they can do that you know that was
for them that's in their law that's they
can do that so I think that's talking
about Jesus and Ezra no it's not that's
you're thinking of another verse this is
talking about the Jews and the
Christians specifically about themselves
they're not talking about anybody else
they're talking about themselves I I I
know it's a different I'm saying in the
context like it's not just all Sons
right like
obviously says the Jews and the
Christians these are the these groups of
people this is what they say we are the
sons of Allah his loved ones that's what
they're say saying about themselves
that's what they believe okay but now
let's continue does Allah accept this
then why does he punish you for your
sins no you are not Sons you are human
beings from who he has created he
forgives who he wills and he punishes
who he wills and to Allah belongs the
Dominion and to him you will return okay
so even the Jews who have that
understanding that God is their Father
Allah says no okay if if that's really
what it means then I'll just take the
apparent meaning then and say that yeah
you can't say your son right all right
so if you say if we're going with what
the Quran plainly says Allah is not a
father to no one and so if you're saying
that you're a son of Allah if you're
saying that God is your father you are
going against Islam and you are not a
muslim okay I wouldn't put it that way
taking people out of Islam again I'm not
that knowledgeable but following your
train of logic like I'm just granting
all of this right then I would say yeah
I'm I'm not Tu fearing anyone here thank
you let me let me ask you this if
someone claimed to be Muslim but said
they believe in three Gods does that
take him out of his mou yeah that's true
and this is the same thing saying that
there somebody yes it is saying somebody
is a son of Allah law that is also Sher
because you're associating because you
can also like Allah looks at the
intentions too if you're thinking of it
in a metaphorical way then obviously
like that's fine no it's not obviously
from the Quran that's not fine but you
don't know like from the quran's
perspective like it's it's talking about
the people who literally take it that
way
no the Jews and the Christians did not
say that they were literal sons of God
they said that they are sons of God his
loved ones he loves them he takes care
of them that's what they were saying and
he says no okay yeah okay then yeah if
that's really what it is then yeah I'll
say no okay so Jesus can't be a Muslim
that's my point from the perspective of
the gospels that we have today yes yeah
that's you know the only perspective we
have of Jesus is from the gospel so
Jesus taught that he was the son of God
he also he also taught that he is the
Son of God who's going to raise the dead
on Judgment Day and judge and decide who
goes to I I believe he's going to judge
I don't know about raising the dead and
all that maybe by B Love by the power of
Allah but oh he no the Bible says this
is what Jesus says he says they're going
to hear the voice of the sons of God in
the grave and the Son of God will raise
them up and he'll send them to either
eternal life or Everlasting judgment
that's what John 5 says okay yeah
brother sounds like God that's pretty
much that's pretty much it I don't know
I'll have to look more into it but uh
yeah the only thing I would say is uh
like when people when Muslims talk about
the inil we are really talking about the
actual words that Jesus spoke we're not
talking about his we're not talking
about his biography we're not talking
about his life about passion narrative
yeah let's talk about that I like that I
like
that I got just I got just the outfit
for that feel like we've heard this
topic before that new Avery could way
for that
man so when we talk about the words of
Jesus you're talking about something
specific
okay cool yeah I'm talking about the W
he received like the actual Revelation
he received y was the Revelation he
received written down was it written
down no hey leave your Quran again man
no because okay listen the Quran was
also not written down when it was
revealed like you know that right like
it was only written down much later
that's that actually works great yeah so
it's written down after the fact yeah
that makes sense so if theil was written
down would have been written down after
yeah but not as after as the current uh
New Testament no well I want you to
check something out for me go to chapter
7 verse
157 go to chapter 7 of uh Quran y of the
Quran reminder chapter 7 57 they are the
ones who follow the messenger the
unlettered prophet whose description
they find in the Torah and the gospel He
commands them to do good and forbid them
from from Evil permits for them what is
lawful forbids to them what is impure
relieves them from their burdens and
shackles which bound them only those who
believe in him honor support him and
follow the light sent down to him will
be successful all right do you read
Arabic at all no no it sucks well the so
you see the word where they said
description his description is found uh
one second where it says his description
is found in the Torah and the
gospel uh okay up at the top of the
verse yeah yeah yeah okay the word
actually is written they find him
written in the Torah and the gospel the
word is in it's right now is an Arabic
speaker you want to confirm with that
yep screen for us thank you DJ those
this is uh chapter 7 verse
157 those who follow the messenger the
prophet unlettered
whom M okay okay y so it's not really
described which I have no problem with
that but it kind of takes away from you
lose the meaning it's actually written
so they find I think that is referring
to the Old Testament when like you know
um like Isaiah and stuff it says written
in the Torah and the inel and the gospel
gospel is not the Old Testament that's
the new so we see here that the re
revelation of Jesus at some point in
time got written down okay my question
is this who wrote it Paul okay Paul
wrote the Paul wrote the Paul wrote the
Paul wrote the okay I I I'm I'm just
gonna be honest I'm not as educated in
this like Realm to be honest on like the
New Testament and stuff so I might get
stuff wrong bro it's okay and and you
won't you came to the right live because
right the other lives will probably like
you know really try to hammer you but
we're chill here so we we we're not here
to embarrass you know you've been clu so
we're we're just talking so
this is what it is would it make sense
to you that the companions of Jesus his
disciples would have written down his
Revelation bits and parts of it yeah the
parts that he spoke definitely his
Revelation right the parts yeah the
actual Revelation yes so is it possible
that in the in their biographies that
they wrote about Jesus that it also
contained the Revelation that Jesus came
with oh yeah I believe that I believe
that there's a lot in Mark for example
that he probably spoke and wrote like
wrote down and stuff yeah do believe
that so then that would mean that
there's no problem with
the uh the style of the the content to
be in a biographical format because
within this biographical format it
contains the Revelation that Jesus
revealed the gospel yeah bits and parts
of it I I would agree so then what you
what we're saying is is that we have the
in we have the in the disciples wrote it
down they gave us the words of Jesus
that they witnessed and heard him
themselves and we know what Jesus said
yeah but you don't know if everything he
said is in there you just know the stuff
that's in there I know that everything
he said is in there everything he said
concerning Revelation is in there the
gospel is in there that's why they're
called The Gospel Mark Mark literally
starts his gospel off with the gospel of
the beginning of the Gospel of Jesus
Christ the son of God and he begins to
write okay okay so if we're talking
about what Jesus revealed which is the
gospel and we have his words we see that
he says a lot of things in there that
goes against his law
now what you say which parts which
parts like can you name some right let
me um let me see if about doing this
because Jesus says something along the
lines of I received this order from my
father so he received this Revelation
from from God right so maybe this is
revelation okay this is a chapter this
is chapter 10 of John verse 17 and 18
this is what it says for this reason the
father loves me because I lay down my
life that I might take it up again no
one takes it from me but I lay it down
of my own accord I have I have authority
to lay it down and I have authority to
take it back up again this charge I have
received from my father so you received
it from God right so this is revelation
so is there like a similar account in uh
Mark or Matthew for that like specific
event or that speech that re similar
similar things are said I mean it's not
the exact same words
but yeah let's let's go to let's go to
Mark let's go to Mark 10 okay and this
is Mark 10 mhm and this is verse 33 this
is Jesus talking see we are going up to
Jerusalem and the son of man will be
will be delivered over to the chief
priests and the scribes and they will
condemn him to death to un living and
deliver him over to the Gentiles they
will mock him spit on him flog him and
kill him unive and after three days he
will rise okay that that is pretty
different but I get the point the
underlying well it's talking to
different audiences but you wanted to
see something similar right yeah yeah I
grant that's kind of similar yeah yeah
okay so so you have in in Mark you have
in Matthew all of them where Jesus says
that he's laying down his life for the
people and giving his life as a ransom
you have in all all the accounts of the
Gospel of Jesus they all say the same
thing they have the same theme the same
thread you know um and if that's what
Jesus is teaching then obviously the
Quran can't be true because it goes
against that well it's right up until
the point where you say he's he's going
to rise again on the third day that's
the yeah that's a discrepancy that's not
the only discrepancy the the fact that
he's he says he's going to be betrayed
and given up to be crucified and he's
going to be crucified he's gonna be
killed he's gonna die that that's that
is a discrepancy okay yeah and the fact
that he's not dead those two things
exactly right so that's that's huge you
get you get rid of that you get rid of
Christianity all together so so um you
have Jesus affirming his death and
affirming his resurrection which the
Quran or Islam I would say just you know
obviously goes against so Jesus is
saying something right and here's the
thing it's not just Jesus that teaches
this the prophets before Jesus said that
the Messiah was going to die for the
sins of the people the prophets taught
this before Jesus came so if you want if
you want to see that I don't I don't
mind showing you that just a couple
verses but but just this is my this is
my thing is the consistency of the
prophets if we can see clear a clear
thread from the prophets teaching the
same thing right one message right
that's what Islam is built on one
message we we're the same way the
prophets are consistent in one message
but the message that the prophets are
consistent on is that they all point to
the Messiah and his I have I have a
legitimate question then why do Jews not
also recognize this then if if it's so
clear from the Old Testament and the old
prophets like wouldn't they also you
know see the same things well they will
see the same things but not all will
believe because you have the people who
are hard-hearted and stubborn right even
the Quran talks about them the Quran
says that signs came to them right the
revelations came do signs can't do I
agree with that I agree with that yeah
worshiping the everything yeah exactly
right right after God just delivered
them from Exodus I mean from Egypt with
all these signs and wonders deeding
pharaoh and his army and they're going
to go and worship a calf just because
they're thirsty and hungry for a few
days that that's the type of people
we're talking
about I agree with that they're very
fickle so yes the truth can be right in
front of their eyes but that doesn't
mean that they'll believe it they'll
still Rebel so fortunately though we do
have you know a group it's not the
majority but it's still a large group of
Jews who do believe in the Messiah you
know they're called Messianic Jews
messian aren't Messi don't Messianic
Jews not believe Jesus as God though no
they believe they believe something
similar to Islam that Jesus was the
Messiah and like all this but he's just
not God no they believe he's God brother
the ebionites the ebionites they're not
IIT okay okay okay I'm thinking of
another group then I'm thinking of the
earliest Jewish groups my bad but also
well there there is there I think a lot
of the ebionites were Jewish but they
had issues among them because they still
believed Jesus was UN Alive by
crucifixion and also they believed he
was not born of a virgin so there's
they're having plenty of problems the
only reason you
find my bad go on okay I was just gonna
say the only reason you know about these
ebionites is because of the church
fathers they don't have their own
writings so so then because I think they
go from the church of James like that's
where they get their teachings from they
don't James James affirmed everything
that the disciples affirmed that's in
the gospel okay they go against what
James James all right well to be honest
I'd have to look into all this yeah look
look into this is what I want you to
look into from from this point I want
you to look into did the prophets
prophesy the death of the Messiah that's
what I want you to check out before you
look into and that that it should be
number one I I do know that they believe
that the Messiah was going to establish
like and restore the kingdom of
Jerusalem on Earth and expand that
Kingdom which Jesus didn't do yeah he's
going to do that when he comes back
which even you believe yeah so that's
that's his second coming first though
first he comes as a humble servant the
suffering servant is what the script the
suffering servant who comes into
Jerusalem not on a high horse but on a
donkey right and he this he's a priest
right the second time he comes well that
man coming on that white horse yeah so
my bad I I meant if those prophecies
were about the Messiah then yeah that
that would make sense yeah but yeah
because I right now I think they're
about Prophet Muhammad obviously alai we
can talk about that mean we can talk
about that
manam
again that is tough man um yeah I
wouldn't focus on like any church
history because that could get lost in
the weeds
um read a gospel and then of course read
what the prophets say um and if you
don't want to do too much homework just
read one gospel read the book of Isaiah
maybe Psalms 22 and Avery your King s
have any they want to recommend no
that's it I just I don't I just want him
to focus on I don't want him to do any
like big readings I just want him to
focus on one subject which is did the
prophets prophesy the death of the
Messiah
theyes that's what I want you to look
into okay agree with that do your
research and we got there is a
crucifixtion all and if I see any uh
rebuttal on that or any uh counter
points I'll come back I'm back to yeah
let us know man all right thanks for
coming man best guest I have all day all
right thank you man bye have a good one
bro thanks for coming you too why can't
the majority be like that that just I
just don't get it I mean I get it I get
it
what I see he you could tell he was
honest because I mean as if any you know
with with any belief system you don't
want to accept it right away so he
didn't want to accept some of the
answers right away but then he started
go along with it okay yeah the Quran
does teach he's not the father and then
he started to accept Okay yeah that does
say that in the Bible so yeah I mean he
was uh he was actually trying to be
honest and not being like fake you know
he wanted to hold on to his beliefs but
then he was honest yes he was sincere at
the you know he started understanding
you know uh you know what you saying and
everything so that's good man that's
what it takes right yeah not for someone
to come here and then just to you know
act arogant and wants to you know oh me
me me that's not going to work like that
it doesn't work like that